boys before we start we have to have to
lovely asmr
special version two
is now live
sorry sorry completely just uh interrupt
you there connor figure special bigger
special
figure special it's happening everyone's
aware everyone's special everyone's been
waiting for it it's the figure special
that's why we're cracking open a cold
one let's
we had some wait more than a year
because we had to wait until akihabara
opened up people getting vaccinated and
um the country letting us finally do
this not even a global pandemic can stop
us from wasting our money on anime
figures well cheers boys cheers to a
successful church cheers cheers cheers
how does it feel to be impressions of a
winner because that's going to be me
today
honestly honestly i'm just i'm here for
the content i can't wait to show you
some of the stuff that i bought
stop being a good sportsman for one
second and talk trash right well no
that's how you lose haven't you learned
from the last special so if you don't
know there are three videos on our own
respective channels where we went to
akihabara and spent three thousand three
hundred and thirty three dollars each a
total of ten thousand dollars between
the trash table which is where budget
which is where the clickbait comes from
we're like we're like we can stretch
this out to ten thousand dollars so we
can put it on the video title and we
have various challenges at those stores
that we can we hopefully completed and
we'll talk about on this episode of the
podcast we have no idea what each other
bought we don't know how many challenges
we've completed and uh yeah today is the
day where we're gonna find out we have
an idea about what the other boys did
but if you wanna find out now before you
watch this then please go watch all of
our videos or you can watch this first
and then go watch the videos kind of
like watching the avengers end game and
then watching iron man either way either
way we'll either watch all of them now
or watch all of them after i would say
watch all of them before but that's just
yeah yeah but they're all up right now
and they're all down in the description
so check them out yeah yeah
and also on our main channels not our
second channel yeah
so basically we're gonna just kind of i
guess run through the products uh well
it's also overarching challenges joey do
you have them all of the the challenges
that aren't for the store they're for
after this they are they are on screen
right now we're not to read them all out
we have 16 of them though yeah we have
16 on them but i think what some of the
notable ones that we remember are like
stuff like buying a figure closest to
the price of 420 and also 69 as well
of course of course i'll be honest i
don't remember much of the other
challenges i don't either so it's gonna
be interesting yeah because by
coincidence if we i remember like in the
first tour i completely forgot we had
overarching challenges and it was only
in the second store that i started to
figure out well we all try to go for the
69 one right i think we all tried for
the city
yeah yeah that was uh that was
interesting it's a lot harder than i
thought it was yeah so uh how did you
boys feel going into this challenge
compared to i mean my challenges that i
got at each store were way easier than
last year which is good so i think i i
have a better chance this year
it's really up to you guys really i
think i think god though got like some
of the harder ones i could i just kept
getting [ __ ] this year man which is
why i was just like you know what i'm
gonna i'm just gonna content that's how
i felt last year
and this guy got an easy road again for
the most part for the most part i think
hard challenges i had to find a a figure
from an anime jerry had watched you know
how hard that is
i had more like finding the the needle
in the haystack
like what are you what are you
this whole store full of anime and jerry
hasn't seen a single one i think uh it
was interesting though because we went
to four stores again this year um two of
them were ones that we've been to
previously which was a stop and army
army yes and then we had two brand new
ones which was rashim bun and mandarake
yeah and uh i think the new stores were
definitely a challenge because yeah
because
it added some spice into the mix because
we didn't know what to expect so
especially ending on mandarake it was so
much risk came into what was in
mandarake because i
hadn't been to akihabara for about a
good year yeah so i literally had no
ideas what would be in any of these
stores right yeah mandarake is truly
like the needle in the haystack store
where like you go in it's it's the don
quixote of [ __ ] phoenix i've found
the coolest stuff in mandarake oh yeah
you also don't find a lot of stuff in
mandarake yeah it's it's either all so i
i'm glad we had some variations yeah
yeah yeah exactly there was a store that
sold everything some stores that didn't
sell anything
and uh some stores that uh had a lot of
loot stuff so that's good yeah yeah yeah
but i mean i was i was kind of nervous
kind of wasn't i it was weird because
this time i wasn't thinking about
decorating as much as i was winning yeah
i was like i don't care about decorating
the office [ __ ] that yeah it's all about
winning by the way if you're brand new
to trash taste the the figures that you
see uh on the backseat are the stuff
that we got last year yeah yeah so so we
only had a budget of five hundred
dollars last time and they got us all
this
uh so we like we
we
what was it six times yeah seven times
the budget six topics sex toppled the
budget i almost believe that the saying
of like constraints make uh the what the
what
what did you say i was like i have sex
this man this man is the oldest one
that's why i tried to not say that
instead i said six times
almost having no limitations well there
was limitations the money was you know
but three thousand dollars is a lot yes
more than one person will ever spend so
i feel like having no limitation nearly
on what you could spend almost made it
harder yeah yeah because you felt like
okay i can buy literally anything now
yeah because before it's like you'd see
a 500 figure yeah and it was like well i
can't believe that was my budget yeah
yeah exactly right you can't buy it so i
almost made it more interesting now you
look for the like the most expensive
figure in the store and you're like okay
this is like a sizeable chunk in my
budget but it's not i'm not going to be
dead in the water even if i buy it yeah
let's just say we didn't find a 3 300
dollar figure
there was some stuff in mandarin
that was definitely like one figure
would have gone our entire budget but
for the most part it definitely felt
like a big difference from last year
yeah to this year right because
like it's a difference between like
being a student and having like a
disposable income that's what it felt
like man
just thinking about some of the [ __ ]
figures i had to spend money on yeah i
know
no because i remember last year i
remember going to a store like a stop i
was looking at figures and like can't
buy that can't buy that can't buy that
and now this time going into a stop i
was like what can i buy let me just let
me just buy it all you know even the
most exciting i'll take your entire
stock yeah it was it was like i'll go
i'll take everything from here to here
yeah and it's like a dent in my body
trash taste season one versus trash
chase season two the peasants versus the
kings what's next it's like who can buy
out all of a stop first
yeah i actually like got to a point
where we got to mandarake and i had
trouble finishing my budget yeah because
because there was like mandarake had
some really really cool [ __ ] but the
really really cool [ __ ] was too
expensive yeah and then some of the
mid-range stuff didn't even make up the
budget i had left because originally it
was like no in between yeah originally i
thought we had three thousand dollars to
spend
um and then only halfway through did i
realize oh no the entire budget was ten
thousand dollars so technically it's
three thousand three hundred thirty
three dollars
um so
so i had to like make up three 300 more
which i didn't think i had in mandarake
yeah yeah yeah um so yeah it was overall
very interesting yeah it's very tough
yeah it was it was a long day as well my
god
yeah it's definitely a long day for sure
it's great it was good fun though i
really enjoyed it i really i really
enjoyed it is it exhausting having to
run around stores for hours a little bit
but it's not nothing i haven't done
before yeah in season one
exactly i definitely felt a lot more
comfortable filming this one than i
didn't see yeah you seem like you're
like kind of digging it more yeah i
remember i remember when we were all
filming our intros i had to get away
from ghant because it was actually
getting too loud like morgues now he's
like what's up guys it's me gigger
you guys spend 24 hours
in russian
he's gotten too good we created a
monster he's just too good for youtube
flashback to season one occupier special
encounters like
how do i say [ __ ] without a script yeah
because i remember when we were filming
season one you boys had finished for
like a good 10 minutes filming your
intro yeah and i don't think i'd even
started filming because i'm like oh
cindy uh am i looking a girl yeah john's
off on the couch like what is anime
anime is so and we're like god
just talking the glow up man it was it
was it was great to see we all did a
much better job actually i think we all
get a lot more confident yeah i think
it's experienced yeah i hope that came
across in the videos you know hopefully
they look better sound better and the
energy's there yeah yeah although most
of the time i did get distracted and i
was so focused on doing the things that
i forgot to actually talk to the camera
a lot of the time i was just so intently
focusing on finding these goddamn
figures that i didn't i didn't think to
present
i would like to hear even though you
should go too long i would like to hear
all of the the overarching challenges
because oh sure i'm sure i think it'd be
good for the viewers to know what
challenges to keep in mind
can you start reviewing so these are the
ones that were separate so tell us you
get from them as well okay so one point
to whoever spends the closest to three
thousand three hundred and thirty three
dollars and thirty three cents to the
deposit uh one point to whoever buys the
most expensive single figure okay uh the
one with the cheapest figure however
loses one point okay
figurine from the lowest rated mal
series gets one point okay uh the most
figurines bought
overall gets one point uh most spent on
one series gets one point most spent on
a non-figure gets one point most spin in
one store gets one point so there's lots
of
room room to wiggle okay uh as we said
earlier whoever spends the closest to 69
on a single figure and whoever spends
closest to 420 on a single figure get
one point
we're counting that as six thousand nine
hundred yen or four hundred and twenty
thousand forty two thousand yen uh
figuring from the highest rated male
series however loses a point that's
that's the normie point you lose
uh if anyone bought a hentai figure
that's a point because uh you know god
forbid you're going against youtube
monetization i totally forgot i had that
too uh i've just remembered what i
bought
uh one point to the most figures bought
from an anime original movie oh okay so
you know any like shinkai movie
movie anything like that uh minus one
point for every funko pop obviously yeah
uh minus one point for every duplicate
character anyone buys and minus two
points for every exact duplicate figure
anyone buys oh i see so we made that
like stakes high because it's like you
know we might you know say for example
gan and i might buy and a stolfo figure
we would lose a point but
joey is a massive stealth of course but
there's like lots of the stalford
figures right from like different makers
so if it's the exact same which i don't
think will happen honestly from the
massive budget we had then it's two
points lost uh and then the final one is
if you fail to spend at least a minimum
of fifty thousand yen at a store or five
hundred dollars you lose a point i think
that was the one we were all kind of
paying attention to yeah yeah i use that
as like a good way to gauge
the rest of my body yeah that would
encourage us not to hoard all our money
for one store yeah yeah exactly yeah and
uh just just if we didn't make it clear
that how we are converting we got we're
going to be saying everything in dollars
but that's just basically taking the yen
price and dividing by a hundred i don't
know this year
it's not exactly right but yeah yeah
that's that's exclusive it's the closest
you can think of it